The universe is a really big place, and the
chances, the conditions where life may exist,
happen in much greater abundance than we originally
thought.
For centuries we have looked up to the stars
and wondered if we are alone in the universe.
But recently, our search for extraterrestrial
life has been less about making contact with
an alien race and more about the search for
some kind of galactic lifeboat.
To look for life, scientists used to focus
on planets in the ‘Goldilocks zone’.
A potentially habitable area that’s neither
too near or too far from our sun - in other
words it’s neither too hot or too cold.
But when Cassini started to send back data
from the systems of Saturn, scientists began
to shift their focus.
From planets to moons.
Saturn has 62 confirmed moons with more being
discovered all the time.
And two of those moons, Titan and Enceladus,
could be habitable.
Thanks to Cassini’s galactic hitch hitcher
- a clam shaped probe called Huygens - we
were able to pierce Titan’s hazy atmosphere
and land on its surface
It's really surprised us.
We see dunes.
We see these river gullies and channels that
have been carved by liquid, but there that
liquid is not water.
It's methane and ethane.
Liquid hydrocarbons that have been forming
just like on Earth how we have clouds and
rain events, the same thing happens on Titan,
but it's with an entirely different set of
molecules.
It's a fascinating alien world and we're just
beginning to scratch the surface in terms
of how complex it is and exactly what is present
there on the surface.
But with lakes of liquid methane and a surface
temperature of minus 290 degrees fahrenheit
- how could Titan possibly be habitable?
Well, to humans, Titan is one of the least
hostile places in the outer solar system.
It has a dense, planet-like atmosphere.
Meaning, even though it’s colder and gets
less light than Earth, it has a dense biochemical
make-up that could sustain life.
Titan’s atmosphere is also quite stable.
Except for thunderstorms at the poles there
are no cataclysmic events to worry about like
cyclones, moonquakes or even cosmic rays.
If you lived on Titan, you could stand on
its surface with just an oxygen mask, and
of course, some very very warm clothing.
But maybe the motivation to colonize Titan
isn’t necessarily about building Earth 2.0;
it might make more sense to think about it
as a way-station, a halfway point to the next
Earth 2.0.
Titan has more hydrocarbon reservoirs, like
a larger reservoir than all of them on Earth
combined.
You need extra gas?
Just go to Titan, scoop up some methane, and
carry on to find a place where you can survive.
It's opening our eyes to the breadth and the
possibilities that exist just in our solar
system alone.
There is another moon in the Saturn system
that scientists are excited about - Enceladus.
It’s smaller than Titan - about 310 miles
in diameter.
And underneath its icy crust is an ocean of
water.
We had no idea that there were liquid water
oceans underneath the icy crusts of some of
these moons.
This is exciting for us because any place
on Earth where we find liquid water, we find
life - every time.
Enceladus, not only is it a key astrobiology
target because of this liquid water, but it
is unique in that that liquid water ocean
is accessible.
We don’t know the exact energy source that
keeps its subsurface ocean liquid.
Cassini was able to sample the plumes erupting
from its surface.
It discovered a hydrothermal chemical makeup
similar to what occurs in the depths of Earth’s
oceans.
NASA’s next missions to icy moons like Saturn’s
Enceladus and Jupiter’s moon Europa, will
hopefully be equipped with instruments for
oceanic studies.
Instruments that are directly targeted to
look for organic molecules and the key biosignatures
of life as we know it, or even life as we
don't know it.
We'll be looking for patterns in organic molecules
that are unique only when life is present.
The discoveries that Cassini, and spacecraft
like Cassini, have made will absolutely help
us try to eventually become not a one planet
civilization.
We can't stay here forever.
For more science documentaries, check out
this one right here.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.